[Music] The
animation that robots come out is almost 100% watched on TV,
and I wondered if it was designed like
this from that point.
[Music]
Sting and Reefy denban by Duvet Zu Powder buno 4 a 5
Size Rover Uzbroby Monne
lw Masaaki Nago who created the samurai  It
started in 2011 and lasted for 6 years in 2017.
Otus revenger to do app for Masation
Discer weeks Up
[Music]
Don't just run by your own power
I had a longing to be able to do it, but it means that it also moves
.
I make things with the feeling that moving things are fun.
4 s army Zujaa tree's roverser here to do
liar girl  I was 8 years old and I wanted
to find out what the goddess was and make something that could be brought closer to that kind of thing.
do Money 2nd part Yavation Nu
remove Zone Tour
5 exe
Why Gwang 2 Spoon 4
Display Display People 8th
[Music]
It's really fun to make this, so it's not fun to make, isn't it fun?
Burns and heavy
It gets dirty and there's nothing fun about it.
I want to turn his heart to it, but it's the robot that is beyond the capabilities of the side human beings, so
even in that respect, it's still different from what I'm drawing.  No
, I think I'm making something that can be nut-over on
me. I think that something that humans have thought about can be realized someday.
It's not the foundation of the child to take it and make something that hurts himself,
but even if I think that if I get a little bit, I can make something even more amazing
[Music]